[Music]
hello
foreign
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
hi welcome to the table my name is don
jacobs and i'm one of the leadership
members here
and i just want to say a big shout out
and welcome to all those who
are here and with us in person and a big
shout out to those of you who are
watching and joining with us
online we are thrilled also that you are
here
uh so i'm just going to start off with
just a quick couple announcements
um so we're doing um we started this
last
sunday uh but we're doing like a
clothing drive um i'm trying to remember
where exactly
it came from i was going to trusted
world that's in garland
and so if you want to if you maybe
forgot to bring your clothes this sunday
or anything like that but you can't drop
them off in the foyer
but bring them next week it's not a big
deal i think i still have actually more
clothes sitting in my closet that can
most
definitely bring for sure um and then
also
um we're going to be having a welcome to
the table
class what this is is just an
opportunity for
if you're interested at all about
learning more about
who we are as as the table group kind of
things that we do
and if you're interested and how you
potentially could maybe fit into
what we're doing and maybe potentially
joining the church make sure you step by
um
brett's gonna be outside the employer as
well after service so you can ask him
how
you get details on how to do that
so um this is all the announcements i
have
so i'm gonna start turning this over and
get
started with just a quick word of prayer
uh lord thank you so much for just this
opportunity
thank you for uh just bringing us here
um
you know just where he came here with
all the different things that may have
been weighing on us this week
um all the different concerns and just
different things we've had to
um just that we've just had to just
wrestle with
and deal with and so we're here um just
to hear from you
and to connect with you i just pray for
each person who is here
and those of us are in line i pray that
you have a special
word for them christ i am praying amen
thank you dawn um yeah josh is going to
get us started with
a song that he chose it's kind of an old
song i never heard of it but
we're all going to learn it today maybe
you already know it so anyways
josh take it away bud
[Music]
uh feel free to stand and you're going
to just please stand
sorry about that we're not packed so
sing really loud
we are called out we are ransom
we are not of this world we're in
we are chosen we are blessed
to give light to the lives of men
[Music]
give us life in community
wake us
this is your time this is your
place we are vessels for breaking
under your brains
[Music]
by the blood
to hear it
our hearts let's carry on
[Music]
you are comfort
miracles from our sin
behind us once again
this is your time this is your
place
[Music]
[Applause]
your grace we
are led by your spirit
you have redeemed us
by the blood of your son
send down your word
we are eager to
hear it ready
our hearts to carry on
yes lord we praise you god and we thank
you for who you are
lord help us to sense your presence
right now lord fill us with your spirit
god let us be open to your love
in my mother's womb
you form me with your hands
known in love by you
before i took a breath
when i doubted lord remind me
[Music]
you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good
you make all things
work together
for your glory
[Music]
and for your name
i see clearly now cause i know
nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistake you're an
artist and a potter i'm the candidate
cause you make all things
work together
for my future
and for my good you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name
[Applause]
and when i doubt it lord remind me
i'm wonderfully made you're an
artist and a potter i'm the canvas
and the clay yes i know nothing
has been wasted no failure
or mistake you're an artist
and a potter i'm the candlestick
as you make all things
work together
for my future
[Music]
and for my good
you make all things
work together
for your glory
and for your name cause you're not
finished with me
you're not finished
[Music]
you're an artist
in the clay
[Music]
are you hurting and broken within
overwhelmed by the weight of your sin
jesus
have you come to the end of yourself
do you thirst for a dream from the well
jesus is calling me
oh come to the altar
the father's arms are
open white forgiveness
was bought with the precious
blood of jesus christ
leave behind your regrets and mistakes
come today there's no reason to
wait jesus is calling
bring your sorrows and trade them for
joy
from the ashes a new life
is born jesus is calling
oh
[Music]
was bought with the precious
blood of jesus christ
[Music]
the father's arms are
blood of jesus
[Music]
see
christ is risen
bow down before him
for he is lord
[Music]
hallelujah
[Applause]
sing hallelujah
christ
[Music]
[Applause]
for he is lord
[Music]
is
[Applause]
was bought with
[Music]
bear your cross as you wait for
the crowd tell the world
yeah father god we are grateful to be
able to gather here today in your name
lord
father i hope and pray that our praise
and worship was pleasing to you lord
pleasing roma to you lord god
we are yours lord we we love you
i pray that you bless brett as he
delivers the message today
be with them and each one of us who are
online god be with them
fill them with your spirit it's your
name jesus we pray
amen
amen y'all can uh be seated
and then kind of just turn to someone
around you you don't have to do the
whole like
big hugs but just you know wave maybe
just like a little you know little
social distance greeting to the people
around you
yes y'all um
it is so good to be with you
um we are um
it's just man what a year i think you'll
agree what a year
and so it's just it's just good to be um
together
and so i want to greet all of you of
course but especially those who are new
and and those of us or those of you
joining us online
we love you lots of love your way to our
extended family
and which is a larger group than normal
with all the
the kovids and everything going on so um
yeah so we miss you all
uh a lot and um you know and
kind of uh something that's been on my
mind i'll get into our new series and
things we're kicking off in just a
second but
um this has been i mean it's it's been a
year but really it's been even just uh
a week lots going on um between the
um the shooting in minneapolis and dante
wright there's
uh and then the kind of continued um
kind of anti-asian violence and things
that's been happening in the country
um and then we had i was actually on
facebook or somewhere a few hours before
and i just heard about there's a
an active shooter situation in austin
texas right i guess close to the
arboretum there or something
um and then there's other active shooter
things going on you know in the country
it's just like
goodness gracious and that can all be
um really heavy and
uh and i know we kind of all you know
track it at different levels
and so um maybe some of you you know are
like you're very emotionally resilient
and
you know you're feeling okay and maybe
others are just like it's really heavy
and so
before i kind of got into the rest of
the message and everything i wanted to
um
just kind of um i think just give us a
little space just for just a minute of
like some quiet
which can feel a little bit awkward i
get it um in you know a space like this
but man if there's anywhere we should be
able to like
come and um kind of lay our burdens
before god
and be okay with a little bit of quiet i
think it should be church
you know um so um we'll do that
it won't take super long but i'll just
have a little quiet and then
i'll pray and we'll kind of get into the
message sound good
okay
lord we cast all our burdens on you
because you care for us you see
us you sustain us
and by your love we trust that you will
carry
us through
the lord so we lean into you
and we say yes to everything that you
have for us
for our communities
our families the people we love or we
trust that you'll sustain us
so give us full hearts god
give us courage to face the days
and may bitterness may
fear not be allowed to
um to have its grip on us god but may we
step into your freedom
as your sons and daughters
we love you lord in christ's name i pray
amen
amen thank you thanks for taking that
time
so um we are kicking off
a new series tonight it's titled
new normal new normal and it felt
it felt like a uh just an appropriate
time with the year that it's been
um it it kind of yeah it felt like a
good time for some reflection
um because i know a lot of people had
very different experiences of this
this pandemic um i spoke and as a pastor
you know i get a little a little kind of
behind the scenes look in ways because i
remember
a week where i believe it was in the
same week or maybe back to back weeks
but it was real close together i talked
with one person
and they were a single person and they
had at this point it was months and
months into the pandemics this would
have been maybe
july or august or september last year
and they had been working from home and
they were
they had basically been alone for
months um some of that was already they
didn't have like a really strong social
system
but even apart for like what little they
had kind of you know withered and
they were um you know just i mean
completely alone
and in that same time i had another
conversation this was with
um someone who had like the young kids
and the whole family and so for them
it wasn't so much loneliness that was
their challenge they were just
overwhelmed
because they were like constant it
wasn't someone so much like big social
scene it was more like they were never
away from people especially their kids
you know so
sort of like people people in their
little house and they're like oh my gosh
i'm being driven crazy like i need space
i need quiet it was so fascinating to
talk with these two people
you know same pandemic two very
different experiences
uh and and another time i remember one
conversation with someone who for them
like um from a job perspective they were
able to work from home honestly the
whole pandemic thing was like
kind of a win in ways like it it um they
were able to work from home it was less
travel you know the whole thing talked
with someone else it was job loss
it was financial ruin it was i mean it's
just the worst and you get these sort of
wild swings and i think probably most of
us
probably somewhere in the middle or
maybe strangely both at the same time
you know where you have these on the
like i know our family um
we have had we really before the
pandemic we were so
busy um which will be a message i think
it's probably next week we'll get into
that um
so busy just going so fast and furious
so for us those first few months like
was honestly it was it was good that
family time
was amazing um and
uh but i know you know again other
people though like lost
people family members friends like it
was incredibly difficult so
i think um and for us i guess even our
fight our family like financially this
was a challenging year
my wife maggie teaches piano lessons she
had to like transition try to teach
five-year-olds piano through online
you know like not yeah she's shaking her
head like uh-uh it was
not easy and then of course we launched
the church about four months before the
pandemic
so
so it was just you know it was it was
just a lot it was like it was beautiful
it was terrible it was like all the
things that can anyone relate to that
like
it had some upside like wow some amazing
moments and oh my gosh that was like the
worst
let's never talk about it again um and
i think that's that's kind of the
paradox of this season so my
where my mind's going is that i think we
can have a tendency in a difficult
season
to want to just kind of move on you know
let's just move on and
the thing is we learn or the only way
that we grow
is in the reflecting the only way we
glean
what god might have for us is in that
reflecting the only way we have a more
healthy new
normal is taking some space for that
reflection so that's what we'll be doing
in the in the coming weeks with this new
normal uh
series so with that in mind the title of
my message tonight
is people in my way
people in my way and uh i'd like us to
do some reflecting on
what's maybe one of the more um obvious
insights from the pandemic i'm kind of
framing in the negative in the title
but to put it in a more positive i think
you know it's it's kind of
um the beauty of community the goodness
of of connection um i mean
how great is it to love and to be loved
uh and that i think um yeah it's such a
gift and that was really kind of driven
home
uh for me in in in fresh ways um that'll
unpack in just a minute i'd like to
start
with his text this is first corinthians
13. um this is quite a famous passage
read by at many a wedding um it's from
the apostle paul so
you might recognize it if you've ever
been to a christian wedding um
and of course paul's not talking here
about um romantic love per se it's not
it's like what he's focused on but
that's often how it's applied um now
there's is a strange little phrase he
uses he says if i speak in the tongues
of men and of angels
which might immediately catch you like
what is he talking about angels
so if you're if you're at all familiar
with um kind of the
um the gift of speaking in tongues this
is kind of
common in the like pentecostal
charismatic wing of the church
it's sort of this ecstatic speech this
feeling of the spirit and then
out comes this language you don't
understand um
i grew up in kind of a charismatic um
background so i'm like this is like
these are my people like this is my
world um i don't know how it's striking
some of you are like that is the
greatest thing i've ever heard
uh it's in the bible and uh at least for
me it doesn't i don't know it's not
strange at all
but uh but i get people have different
experiences now what i think is
interesting
about where paul takes this is um he
is it's interesting you can kind of hear
as we'll read in just a second he is
kind of
he's offering a certain critique because
what you can hear is basically him
naming
um even if i have these amazing
spiritual experiences even if i
speak the language of heaven itself
which is like wow
but where does it go but i do not have
love then what i am a
these are great good metaphors here by
paul i am a resounding
gong or a clanging symbol
whoever had uh maybe someone have to do
like drum practice
in your house or if you have little kids
and like banging on like
i mean what's that a picture of i mean
he's basically saying you can have
amazing spiritual experiences
you can like just be awesome and yet if
you don't have
love in your heart not only is it
nothing which you'll say later in the
passage we'll get to that um towards the
end of the message
not only is it kind of nothing or it's
like a mute point
a moot point i should say but it's
actually annoying
that interesting um
so i i lean in terms of just personality
i lean more towards the introverted than
the extroverted
kind of side of human personality
which meant that in the early months of
the pandemic
honestly i was okay
um if you asked me like oh my gosh brett
was this so hard it was just so hard not
to be around like people and
did you miss us okay i did i did i miss
you guys
but i wasn't like you know crying i was
like it was okay i was like okay because
probably i have a very peopley job
and honestly i'm an introvert living in
an extrovert world you know it's sort of
like come on people people being social
things and you know kids going to their
things
so honestly those early days like it
wasn't i don't know it wasn't
so bad i i kind of liked it although
here's the thing it was fine for like
three months
somewhere around like 12 14 16 weeks
after a while like it
started to sink in any other introverts
have this experience
or like the early days like okay you're
doing your puzzles and
you know chilling watching your netflix
right but at some point
you know for the extroverts it was in
like three days you're like oh my gosh
i'm gonna go crazy
but you know insurance is a little
different and this is how it would
happen it just kind of hit me
like within around probably may early
may of last year like oh my gosh
i need to be around people and it just
basically what started to occur to me
was that i had basically i had been
taking
people for granted um
because i just always had hugs and
handshakes
and you know like the thousand little
ways
eye contact and like human connection i
just always had
more of that like than i could have ever
dreamed in my life
and so it wasn't until it was taken away
that i realized oh my gosh
i've been taking people for granted
i realize honestly this is bad as a
pastor i had taken church for granted
i remember back in november i came
actually i sat right there and i
attended a service here at pleasant
valley united methodist church on their
sunday mornings
this is the place obviously we rented
out in the evenings um so i came because
we were
myself and sarah john's we were kind of
scouting out to see like how they do
things because we were hoping to kind of
reopen sooner and then the numbers went
like
and so that didn't happen but we were
kind of scouting out hoping and so i
remember sitting right there
and like i could have cried like just to
be
i mean it was and it was like you know
pretty sparse kind of like we are like
just a few people you know nothing crazy
weren't like 100 people so it was just
you know 20
25 people and i was like oh my gosh and
the band's like music's playing
and just people are talking to me before
and after the service i'm like
hi there yeah hey like it was
uh amazing i realized i had taken
church for granted
um another experience i had this just a
few weeks ago i went to
my nephew's first t-ball game
i was there in wiley texas and we went
out and we sat
and i i mean again
i just realized i had taken all this for
granted because we're sitting there
it's like people are smiling it's a
beautiful day we're like cheering on the
little kids they're doing cutesy things
you know and it was like this sense of
kind of camaraderie
here we all are like yay and
and before the pandemic i was just like
oh my gosh another game another kid's
game you know i was good i was a
terrible person i was i was terrible
and just to be there with other people i
saw people i hadn't seen in a year
and they're just like hey i'm just
talking oh my gosh i had
taken it um for granted
even meetings like business church or in
my context is church but you know
you'll have you know like business
meetings or things i and i realized even
the way all that of course or a lot of
that has been online now
but to be able to interact with someone
like what happens before and after a
normal meeting even if you have an
agenda and things to do what do you do
you chit-chat before and after you know
just like hey what's up how are you
i it wasn't until it was all taken away
that i realized oh
my gosh i have taken it all for granted
it was all precious
it was all beautiful i'm so grateful
like
i didn't realize it's the old cliche
right don't know what you
got till it's gone like it was that was
exactly
the experience um that i had i've been
taking
people for granted and so here's the
question
that i've been kind of mulling over the
past few weeks
um what if it's not just me or even i
see a few of you naughty in your head so
assuming you know a few of you are
connecting with this
but what if it's not just me and not
just us that have been doing this but
what if
really as a culture
long before the pandemic
what if we have all been very prone
to take people for granted
in other words what if we have often
seen people
or maybe i'll just say too often we have
as somehow in the way of our life
instead of them being
the precious way that
is our life does that make sense like
they they're not in the way they are the
way they're not in the way of my life
they like are my life like these
interactions these these people
you all my family my friends my right
like people like this is so much of our
life
and honestly this is how god like meets
us and yet
um so often and i'll just speak in the
singular here i'm not trying to put it
on all of you
but too often i have seen people as
in my way um here's a story
that plays out over and over and over
again in our
um in our culture a person they work at
a job
for like a long time you know 25 30 35
years
and the whole time they thought the
primary
point of their job was what
the job right like doing the
things on the list and then they have
like their retirement party
and you know people show up and like see
all the people and then suddenly
it dawns on them that all of these
people that they
you know had spent quite a bit of time
being mostly annoyed with
but all of a sudden what do they realize
like it hits them right
that what was the most beautiful
meaningful part of the whole
thing what was it i should say who was
it
it's the people right it was the
relationships it was the
it was the connection like that's what
it was
actually really about at least um even i
mean i'm not saying to-do lists don't
matter and things right you have your
job you got to do your job
but i think the point is we just too
often we get so distracted and so
focused on
i've got to get somewhere i've got to do
the thing i've got to
succeed in some way that it's like
people
are in my way
instead of they are the way
they are the way here's another
story that plays out over and over and
over again in our culture uh you have a
parent
and they have an amazing job i mean it's
one that people envy
they they they do very very well
but like every job has its trades has
its trade-offs and the trade-off is
uh it's long hours and even when they
are home um
they just they don't have much to give
right emotionally it's like they've kind
of given it all elsewhere and they get
home
and the kids are like let's play you
know and they're just like oh my gosh i
just don't have much
to give and the story they tell
themselves
to kind of justify it is well i
am providing a life for them
that they would not have otherwise and
honestly they need
all of these things all these things
that i give them they
they need all the fancy things um
but what is that what's that parent like
what are they missing
what's the primary thing like what's the
primary gift of a parent
it's not a big like fancy check is it
what's the primary gift of a parent it's
their presence
not you know what i mean presents e and
c e presents
right it's the it's the connection
like that's that's the thing the the
family family's not in my way
to some other goal that like is really
important
um they are the way and of course i'm
not trying to like shame anyone i get
life happens sometimes you mis you know
you miss susie's soccer game or you have
the crazy week and you work late or busy
season or whatever right my point's not
to shame
but maybe i'll just say if you haven't
been to susie's soccer game in two years
it might be time to rethink the
[Music]
priorities
yeah but we keep forgetting this don't
we
we just keep drifting from this truth
and why because the culture keeps
drifting from this truth
and it's like it's sort of like the tide
we just get pulled
right out with everyone else into
thinking into the great lie that people
are in our way rather than them being
the way and i think um the way i want to
kind of break this down tonight is in
two ways i want to look at two traps
because i think this happens i don't
personally don't really believe in the
whole sacred secular split
of the world i think this is god's world
god is present everywhere there's you
know where you can go where god is not
but i do think for shorthand it can be
kind of a helpful way to think
at times so i'm going to talk tonight
about the a secular trap and then a
religious trap
two ways that this plays out uh and then
i will be done
um so here's the first the first trap is
the secular trap
this is when wealth titles and status
become more important than loving
relationships
this is the way i think it plays out in
kind of a more secular space
um wealth title status right this is
what we start to pursue
and this is why people become in our way
because we're like we're going onward
and upward towards these
awesome things that you know actually
people really respect
and uh that's what i'm going for right
there's a wonderful book if you haven't
heard of this book or gotten
it you all should though i know not
everyone's a reader of books but if you
are
this book is wonderful it's titled a
general theory of love
written by psychiatrists um and
co-authors richard lannon
fari amini and thomas lewis and they
basically
um they do pull a lot on neuroscience to
talk about the ways that our
our brains what they call the kind of
limbic part of our brain this kind of um
emotional feeling part of our brains how
it
it connects it syncs up it links up with
others through things like hormones
through body language mood basically it
says it's all contagious
some of you have tonight like you've
caught certain emotions from people that
you've interacted with you didn't have
to think about it
it just happened this is why when
someone like greets you and they're
smiling they're like hey oh my gosh
it's so good to see you you start to
feel better
you can't help it even if you're like no
i'm gonna be angry
you can't help it a smile a right it
starts to connect
and the reverse is true as well and so
what they do is they kind of
they wrote this brilliant book talking
about how this happens how um
it impacts you know parents to children
have a powerful effect on
their kind of emotional state and what
becomes their emotional
normal and they may just unpack this is
why for example therapy works
you get into a relationship with someone
who hopefully if the therapist is good
is emotionally stable empathetic a good
listener
and you start to tune into them now
where they also go and the reason i
bring it up now
is because they name why our society
dangerously ignores this process all of
the relating
and the loving and the connecting why we
ignore it to our peril this is a lengthy
quote but i think it's it's worth
um reading a full they say this
relational pursuits
sink slowly and steadily lower on
america's list
of collective priorities top ranking
items remain
the pursuit of wealth physical beauty
youthful appearance and the shifting
elusive markers of status
does that sound familiar to anyone in
the culture like yeah
there are brief spasms of pleasure to be
had at the end of those pursuits
the razor thin delight of the latest
purchase
the momentary glee of flaunting this
promotion
or that unnecessary trinket you can tell
they're being a little brutal
but if you've had that moment right of
like ooh the new thing it lasts for like
24 hours you know
pleasure here but not contentment
happiness is within range only for
skillful people
who give the slip to america's values
these rebels will necessarily forego
exalted titles and glamorous friends
exotic vacations washboard abs
designer everything all the proud
indicators of
upward mobility and in exchange
they may just get a chance at a decent
life what are they naming
they're naming the secular trap
they're naming the way that we are all
tempted
oh and social media just takes this and
puts it on steroids
because now we're all projecting we're
all even if we don't have it
we can pretend and so now it's like yeah
i mean have you heard of people doing
advertisements where they like
they rent a ferrari they get a bunch of
fake
money and then they like make ads based
on like i'm successful buy my
video series on how to be and it's all
fake it's all
they rented the helicopter or whatever
you know like and this
this is what we're projecting this
wealth status
because that's gonna be a great life
it's the secular trap
it's a trap it's it's in the end
there's so much emptiness there
because the real meaning the depth the
beauty of life
where is it found in
loving and being loved people
relationships connection
that's where all the good stuff is and
hey if you get a helicopter i mean good
for you congrats
but but without love you remember
the passage without love
it's nothing right now you might say
well here's the thing brett i agree
that is so shallow
but i'm a religious person a
spiritual person a christian
person i don't go in for all that you
know
outward success and the trappings
of you know looking good on social media
oh forget all that
i'm into other things you know spiritual
things and of course this takes this
there's a lot of different ways this
plays out there's more of like a
christianity version of this religious
then there's like
um even different flavors of
christianity people do there's then
kind of a more new age spiritual kind of
way to do this there's
all sorts of ways that we fall into this
religious trap but i'll just give a few
bullet points to kind of like start
hitting on it you know
so i don't care about that secular stuff
brett i care about things like
biblical knowledge positive thinking
christian tradition and orthodox belief
spirituality realizing my higher self
activism bringing about the kingdom of
god on earth as it is in heaven
attaining higher states of spiritual
consciousness praying
a lot meditating a lot spiritual
disciplines to become the best me
that i can be any of that sound familiar
like brett you've preached on some of
that okay we'll get to that in a second
i'm not saying these things are bad
but what happens right if there's a a
secular trap
of wealth and status and like that's the
most important thing then we
it's weird we kind of invert it and like
we do a religious
version of this um
and so here's the religious trap just
give you this clear definition this is
when biblical knowledge
and rule following and religiously
motivated activism and my
endless self-improvement projects become
more important than being a loving
person in loving relationships
that's the trap and i fall into this
trap
um here's my one of my most embarrassing
moments as a person who calls themselves
a christian so i am
this especially happened back when my
kids were younger
um they're getting a little older a
little better about knocking now but i
would be in my
my little my little room it's the piano
room and that's where i say my prayers
in the morning so i'd be like either
praying or reading scripture doing my
you know christian devotional kind of
thing
and then i'm in the morning and one of
my kids would just burst in and they're
just like hey
oh sorry that's a little loud they're
like hey they're like i need water you
know or some
requests at 7 00 am just like i need
water i need this and i would and i'm
like in the zone
you know i'm in the zone i'd be like
i would just get so i think it was
probably because that's why it's my own
little me time
it's my meeting you know and i just felt
my space i'm an enneagram five for those
of you who care about such things
so this is probably part of the reason
this is how my center side comes out and
i'm just like
get out of here like get out
and i would kind of like i would get
real upset now
why is that so um stupid and
embarrassing
because the whole point
of my bible reading and praying
is supposed to be what
loving right
i am supposed to be the place where the
love of god
is happening and so it is
just the absolute height of
my ego and stupidity
that in that very moment where i'm
literally i mean often my prayers are
god
fill me with your love transform me like
this is my prayer
and i'm like get out of here like
what is going on it's the religious trap
it's the religious trap
and of course to be clear i'm not saying
you know that memorizing bible verses or
marching for justice or whatever you
want like obviously that list
those are beautiful things as long as
they're leading you
to a place where the love of christ is
happening
in you in me then it's awesome that's
great
but the moment we start to think of
people as in our way
to some higher ideal
some other thing whether spiritual or
whatever that's that's when
um we've lost the plot of the story
that's when we've we've lost
our path on the journey we've fallen
into the religious
trap and this is why the apostle paul
warns us of the religious trap first
corinthians 13.
i'm going to keep reading he starts with
the verse one that we already read if i
speak in the tongues of men or of angels
but do not have love
i'm only resounding gong or a clanging
symbol
and if i have the gift of prophecy and i
can
fathom all mysteries and all knowledge
and if i have a faith that can move
mountains there's echoes there of the
teachings of jesus right if you have the
faith of a mustard seed you can move
them and paul is saying
if you have that you can do you can do
that
but do not have love
nothing i'm nothing
and if i give all i possess to the poor
and give over my body to hardship that i
may boast
but i do not have love i gain nothing
because what is love about what you say
what is god about
love is patient it's kind it does not
envy
it does not boast it does not dishonor
others it is not self-seeking
i think that's a key word for all we're
talking about in the secular trap the
religious trap what happens
it's you you can even seek the self
yourself even in church
but true love is not self-seeking
it is not easily angered that's the word
to me
it keeps no record of wrongs love does
not delight
and evil but rejoices with the truth it
always protects
always trusts always hopes always
perseveres
love never fails that's
what true christian spirituality is all
about
so in closing um
never forget people are not in your way
people are the way so don't fall into
the secular trap of
thinking people are in the way or the
churchy religious
trap spirituality trap of believing
people are in your way
they're not in the way they they are
the way and if uh man if we've learned
anything from a pandemic in a year of
way too much isolation it's the goodness
of connection the value of people
and so and as a community
let's do our best to learn the lesson
sound good all right let me pray for you
lord jesus
i thank you um
i thank you for this community and i
thank you
for the love um
is in in so many of these people's
hearts
and god i pray that this year this next
year god you would deepen it
that we would learn all that you want us
to learn and
that we wouldn't um
that we wouldn't take people for granted
anymore god
yeah help us to value help us to
treasure people
as the marvelous glorious beautiful end
that they are
help us to love well god that's our
prayer
it's in the powerful life-changing name
of jesus that i pray
amen
um so yeah let's all stand together and
we're gonna
end where we started with carrier love
it's only a fitting song
for brett's message and a good reminder
for us all
[Music]
we are called down
give us
[Music]
this is your
place we are vessels for
breaking under
[Music]
by
here ready our hearts carry on
you are comfortable
[Music]
render miracles from our sin
remind us once again
this is your
place we are vessels for breaking
under your graves
we are led by your
spirit
[Applause]
[Music]
your grace we
are led by your spirit
you have redeemed us
by the
[Music]
we are eager to
hear
[Music]
thank you guys for coming out and
worshiping with us tonight
and um yeah we thank you brett for that
message help us to remember the things
that are important
our friends our family
our relationships god especially our
relationship with you lord
help us to be your hands and feet we
love you it's in your name you pray
jesus
amen and you are dismissed
oh one more thing don oh my bad you're
not dismissed
don will dismiss you
[Music]
oh gosh thank you guys so much um so it
was really interesting and listening
to brett a little bit because i most
definitely had a moment
when we were social distance and
i live in an area where
[Music]
a church can come and rent out a very
open space
and there was a time where the church
came out and they sang worship music
in person and it was similar to what
your experience was i
started crying because i had not had
that experience
in so long so one of the reasons why i'm
so thankful that we are meeting in
person is for
just seeing you guys um seeing faces
seeing
um each other and then being able just
to come together
in a community and be able to worship
together it's amazing
absolutely amazing so just a couple of
reminders
um don't forget about the um the closing
drive as i mentioned before
um and then of course the um if you're
interested
in learning more about how you can
connect more with us possibly even
i'm even joining the church um speak
with brett he'll be outside
at the foyer and i'm just going to send
you off with this benediction
so may the blessing of god go before you
may god's grace and peace abound
may god's spirit live within you may
god's love
wrap you round may god's blessing remain
with you always
and may you walk on holy ground amen
now you're dismissed this time
you